what do you recommend to a writer that's
too much of a perfectionist and on the
flip side one that's too loose and maybe
a little sloppy if you're too much of a
perfectionist you need to understand
that you need to get it out the door at
a certain point or drop that script and
move on to another a writer writes they
write more than one script you can't
obsess over the same script for years
I've done it everybody does it you know
if it's your baby and you want it to be
perfect it's good that you want to be
super detail-oriented and you want it to
be of a high quality level and not have
any typos or spelling errors and really
blow away the reader so it's gonna take
some time to write it's gonna take years
for you to get the skills to write that
great breakthrough script but you have
to get it out the door at some point or
drop it and move on so if you're
planning to get it out the door then you
have to cut it off at some point and say
I'm going to submit this to a contest or
a manager or a producer or whoever and
it's tough it's tough to get it out the
door because you're never sure if it's
exactly ready you know but it's probably
never gonna be perfect it's probably
never going to be the exact submission
ready level that that needs to be it's
just it's subjective you know to the
reader so it's hard to say okay this is
absolutely where you should cut it off
and you should send it out the door it's
your choice and it's one of the toughest
choices for writers you know when do you
submit
you